A record rainfall has killed at least 8 people...
...in and around the South Korean capital Seoul...
...according to authorities on Tuesday.
Torrential rain has knocked out power lines,...
...caused landslides and submerged roads and subways...
...across the capital and in a neighboring province.
In Seoul's glitzy Gangnam district,...
...buildings flooded and vehicles have been submerged,...
...leaving many stranded.
Official data shows at least 765 facilities have been damaged...
...while around 52 highways and roads have been blocked.
Hundreds have also been evacuated from their homes.
Visiting a flood-hit area of Seoul on Tuesday,...
...President Lee Seok-yeol blamed climate change.
The intense heavy rain that broke the record for hourly precipitation...
...in Korea's meteorological history...
...is believed to be due to abnormal weather conditions caused by climate change.
The government should review the current disaster management system from scratch,...
...taking into account these abnormal weather conditions caused by climate change.